the ruling class
really really wants us to eat bugs
they
they really want it this has become a
meme
people will say i will not live in the
pod i will not eat the bugs i will not
consume and and the ruling class keeps
trying to force us to do it they don't
want us to live in nice big houses they
don't want us to go to uh work and to
our community and to our church into
stores they want us to live in a tiny
little pod in a metropolitan area and
they want us to eat bugs from bloomberg
why bugs must have
a bigger part of the human food chain
they're fine for snacking but insect
protein
i like how they just assume that part
yeah sure they're fine for snacking but
we need to do more of that uh hold on
i'm a little skeptical of the first
premise
they write
quote humans have been consuming edible
insects from crickets and grasshoppers
to fire ants and termites since before
the dawn of civilization about 80
percent of the world's population
throughout asia africa and latin america
continues to eat bugs today
that's true
i think that's true
but
i think they're hiding the ball a little
bit
i think because i think the operative
word here is before
you're saying people ate bugs
before civilization that's true
and then we got civilization and
civilization's pretty great guys
i
love civilization
i now what they're saying though is
even after the dawn of civilization in
the civilized world some places continue
to eat bugs such as in asia
and africa and latin america first of
all this is painting with a very very
broad brush
there are lots of people
who are
wealthy who have been
civilized to have interactions say with
the west who are in asia africa and
latin america who don't eat bugs but
it's true there are some very very poor
people
some tribal people there are many tribal
people actually in all of those places
who still eat bugs and who live in a
very uncivilized way
that's bad we shouldn't want to do that
i don't i don't want to live
like a peasant in the middle of some
jungle in vietnam i want to live like a
civilized person with the cultural
inheritance that our forebears gave us
this beautiful thing that we are
squandering
but it's not look i'm going to continue
to do that i'm not going to eat the bugs
the bugs are gross
and guess what the people pushing this
mike bloomberg he ain't going to eat the
bugs
bill gates he ain't going to eat the
bugs all the hollywood celebrities all
the global political elites none of them
are going to eat the bugs they don't
want to because bugs are gross they're
going to eat filet mignon they're going
to eat caviar they're going to eat foie
gras and you you dirty rotten peasants
you're going to eat the buds you're the
bugs and you're going to live in your
pod and you're not going to own anything
and you're going to like it by golly i'm
glad you like that clip i'm glad you
showed up now if you want to show up for
more clips you got to ring the bell
subscribe get those notifications
i hope you get the notifications even
once you ring that bell if you don't
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in do to do the
michael knowles show doo doo doo
subscribe leave a five star review boom
boom boom doo doo hack the mainframe
you're all good we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you